Isaiah
43:10, "Ye are my witnesses, sayaith the
Lord, Jehovah, Yahovah, and my servant
whom I have chosen, that ye may know and
believe me, and understand that I am he.
Before me there was no God formed,
neither shall there be after me." So
Steven is wondering, isn't this plain as
day? There is no other god besides
Yhovah. Jehovah, there is no other
God alongside Jehovah. No God exists
before him, no God after him. Isn't that
plain as day? Wouldn't this settle the
problem? There can't be any other god of
any other kind besides Yahweh, Yhovah,
Jehovah. No, this doesn't prove it. Can
you understand what his question is? His
question is, wouldn't this prove there
can't be other gods? No, it it can't.
Guys, focus and don't let people get you
into side issues and tangents because I
want you to learn from the questions.
Even though it may not be your question,
you will still learn and be sharpened
because these questions are addressing a
variety of topics that we all need to be
well verssed in for the glory of Jesus
Christ. And we're trusting the spirit to
give us the correct answers because
truth comes from him. Okay. Now, focus.
The Bible will often use language such
as no one, only one, and one without
excluding others. Are you with me there,
Stephen? I want you listen to me. In the
two articles I gave you, the two
articles I gave you, I give you examples
where the Bible will use language such
as one and only one, none else, no
other. And yet there will be others who
also share in a specific function or
characteristic that the Bible says
belong to only one entity. For example,
the Bible says in Mark 10:18, there's
none good but God. Only God is good.
Right? Only God is
good. Okay? But now that's Mark 10:18.
And the Greek word is agathos in the
article that I gave you. However, there
are many other people are good. Here,
let me quote it for you. Look, Stephen.
Mark 10:18. Only God is good. Agathos is
the word. Okay, but hold on. Luke 23:50.
Now, there was a man named Joseph from
the Jewish town of Arya, who is a member
of the council, a good and righteous
man, Agathos. We have a contradiction,
Stephen. Only God is good, but so is
Joseph. Either Joseph is God or we have
a contradiction. Or there's a third
option. Either Joseph is God or we have
option. And what's the third option? The
third option is when the Bible says that
God is the only one who's good. It means
he's good in such a way that doesn't
apply to others who can be good but not
in the same sense that God is. Let me
repeat it
again. You can have someone who's good
but not in the sense that God is. God is
good in a sense in which others are
excluded. Only God is good in this
particular sense. Others are good in a
relative sense but not in the same sense
that God
is. You see how the Bible works. You see
the biblical
language. But wait, it says only God is
good. No one else. No, Joseph is good.
Now, let me give you other examples from
my articles. This is why I keep
encouraging you guys. I keep encouraging
guys study the materials not because I
want to be famous and you guys look at
me as God's gift apologetics. No,
because these arguments we've addressed
thoroughly in our articles, rebuttals,
and sessions. Study them, eat them up,
disseminate them, share them for the
glory of Christ. Here's another example.
Barnabas in Acts 11 22- 24. I'm not
going to read quote all of it. Acts
11:22-24. Stephen, notice this. Acts 11
22- 24. Watch this,
Stephen. For he was a good man. Barnabas
was a good man. Agathos filled with the
Holy Spirit and faith. Hold on. Wait,
wait, wait, Luke. Wait, wait, Luke. You
just said in your own gospel, Luke 18:1
19, that Jesus said only God is good.
Didn't you say that, Luke? Yeah, I I I I
wrote that Luke 18:19. But then he said,
Joseph and Barnabas, they're good. So
Luke, either that means Joseph and
Barnabas are members of the Godhead or
you're contradicting yourself or there's
a third
option. There's a third option. What's
the third option? Yes, God alone is good
in that sense of goodness. Others are
good in a relative sense. Now, I can
multiply examples, but did you save the
links to my
articles? Did you save the links to my
articles? because if you did then I can
skip giving you further examples and I
can just get to the meat of the point.
All right, what's the point? A
henotheist will tell you yes there is no
other god besides Yahweh Jehovah in the
sense in which Jehovah is God. In other
words, Jehovah is the only God of that
kind. Jehovah is a specific kind of God.
There is no other God like that kind of
God. That's all it's saying.
You get my
point? Jehovah is a specific particular
special kind of deity. There is no other
deity like Jehovah. So these other gods,
they're not like Jehovah. So yes, there
is no God like Jehovah. There is no
other god that is God in the same sense
that Jehovah is. That's what they'll
tell you Isaiah 43:10 is
saying. Are you with me there?
So let's say that doesn't prove your
point. That doesn't prove your
point. You get what I'm saying? But I
will give you a passage that shows no
other kind of god exists in any
sense. There is no other kind of god.
There's only one god. There are no
lesser gods because no other kind of god
exists at all. I'll give you a verse for
that. Are you
ready? I can give you a verse. Galatians
4:8, Steven Universe. Galatians
4:8. Guys, we're up to like 175. Praise
God. We're increasing because we're
going to do marathon sessions today. At
least three if God is pleased. Galatians
4:8. Stephen, this is for you. Galatians
4:8.
How be it then, when you knew not God,
ye did service unto them which by nature
are no gods. Pay attention,
Stephen. Paul is talking to Gentiles who
were
enslaved by the powers and p
principalities of the heavenly realms
that deceive them into thinking they
were the gods and goddesses worshiped by
the nations.
In other words, these would be the very
gods that Michael
Heiser claims are the gods of the
council. These spirit rulers who
enslaved the nations as part of God's
judgment upon them. These spirit rulers
who appeared as the gods and goddesses
of the nations like Zeus and and
Baal. And these people were enslaved to
them and served them. But now God has
set them free. But you understand what
Paul said about those
gods. They are not gods at all. They
were no gods by nature. They were not
gods at all. They did not have divine
nature. Even in a lesser sense, you
serve those who by nature were not gods.
They were not gods at all. Not that they
were not gods in the way Jehovah's God.
They're not gods. Period.
Galatians 4:es
8-13. I'm trying to help you make the
best case to show hentheism does not
exist because these gods are not gods at
all. They're falsely viewed as gods or
they're gods in a functional sense, but
they are not divine in nature in the
sense that they are lesser gods. Gods of
a different sort. I'm sorry. Galatians
4:8-13. You guys checked out first to
last brought us and let me know so I can
start reading. Galatians
4:8-13. Let's read. How be it then, when
ye knew not God, ye did service unto
them which by nature are no gods. But
now, after that you have known God, or
rather are known of God, how ye turn
again to the weak and beggarly
elements, elements, elemental spirits,
where to ye desire again to be in
bondage. Ye observe days and months and
times and years. I'm afraid of you, lest
I have bestowed upon you labor in vain.
I wasted my time with you. Brethren, I
beseech you, be as I am, for I am as ye
are. You have not injured me at all. You
know how through the infirmity of the
flesh, I preach the gospel unto you at
the first. Now, notice Galatians 4:9
posted in the ESV. What are these
elements that he's referring to or NIV?
These are the elemental spirits, meaning
the spirits that control and influence
the nations. Did you catch it? Galatians
4:9. But now that you have come to know
God, or rather to be known by God, how
can you turn back again to the weak and
worthless elementary principles of the
world? Those are the gods he's referring
to, not the
idols. The principles of the world, the
elementary spirits that influence the
world, that permeate the world,
influence them to corrupt themselves and
rebel against God. Those are the ones
that are not gods. It's not referring to
idols, but the spirits, the
principalities that influence nations to
defy God, to sin, to war against each
other, to hate, to steal, to murder, to
spread corruption. They are no gods by
nature.
So if there are no gods by nature, but
these are the gods that rule over the
nations, that means this heavenly
council where the sons of God rule over
the nations, they are no gods at all.
They are by nature no gods. So much for
hetheism. You get my point now? I'm
trying to make it easy for you to refute
heentheism. Now for the record, if
henotheism is biblical, I'll accept it.
If the Bible teaches it, amen. But
because of Galatians 4:8, I cannot
accept that these gods are lesser gods
in nature. They do possess the nature of
divinity. Because Galatians 4:8 is not
about the idols, about the
principalities, the elements, meaning
the spirits permeating the nations,
corrupting the nations, enslaving the
nations. He says those spirits, these
principles, principalities, elementary
spirits, they are not gods at all. They
are by nature no gods at all.